chào các bạn video này sẽ hướng dẫn các
bạn các cái thao tác trên đối tượng word
ác hay còn gọi là Phong chữ nghệ
thuật như ở trên bên trái màn hình cái
đối tượng Microsoft Word hay là tăng
cường hỗ trợ các trang web đó chính là
các đối tượng Quốc ác và bây giờ thao
tác đầu tiên là tạo chúng ta
chọn cùng từ cần chuyển thành quốc
ác vào thẻ
Insert chọn Quốc ác sau đó chọn
kiểu sau khi chúng ta tạo Quốc ác thì
thao tác tiếp theo là chúng ta có thể
hiệu chỉnh màu sắc và màu sắc thì nó có
hai loại Đó là màu sắc của cái khung bao
quanh Quốc ác và màu sắc của cái chữ thì
để thao tác trên màu của cái khung thì
chúng ta vào set format chúng ta chọn
lệnh là set
field và chúng ta chọn màu
đây tiếp tục chúng ta vào save outline
chúng ta chọn màu để xác định cái đường
viền màu đường viền Nếu nó cái màu này
nó nhạc thì chúng ta sẽ vào tiếp set
outline chúng ta chọn way và và chọn cho
nó đậm hơn và có thể đối tượng qu ác
chúng ta không dùng cái màu sắc này thì
chúng ta có thể bỏ nó đi bằng cách vào
lại set field và chúng ta chọn no
field vào set outline chúng ta chọn no
outline đó là thao tác với màu sắc của
cái đối tượng chứa Quốc ác bây giờ chúng
ta sẽ thao tác với màu sắc của cái dòng
Microsoft Word hay hay còn gọi là màu
sắc của test thì ch chúng ta sẽ vào co
lệnh T fiel và chọn
màu tiếp tục test outline màu của đường
viền thao tác tiếp theo là chúng ta có
thể thực hiện đó là hiệu hiệu chỉnh cái
hiệu ứng của đội tượng Quốc ác chúng ta
vào save format chúng ta chọn lệnh test
effect và chọn transform và sau đó chúng
ta chọn các cái hiệu
ứng
à
nhắp
à thao tác tiếp theo chúng ta có thể
thực hiện đó là chúng ta định dạng hiệu
ứng bóng độ cho đối tượng
ốc ác chúng ta vào lại lệnh test effect
Và đây là các K hiệu ứng khác
nhau đây là các cái nhóm hiệu ứng khác
nhau Sadow hay là reflection hay là glow
Vân Vân chúng ta có các cái hiệu ứng
khác nhau và ở đây minh họa là chúng ta
sẽ chọn
saad và
chọn outer Tức là cái hiệu ứng ở bên
ngoài rồi nhắp chuột vào chúng ta có
được hiệu ứng cho đối tượng Quốc ác và
cuối cùng nữa nếu sau khi chúng ta tạo
tạo đối tượng Quốc ác mà chúng ch ta
thấy rằng cái kiểu này nó không phù hợp
thì chúng ta có thể đổi sang kiểu khác
bằng
cách chúng ta vào lại là set format và
chúng ta chọn cái
kiểu chúng ta sẽ chọn kiểu đó là Quick
siz và chúng ta chọn lại kiểu khác
đây đó là các thao tác với đối tượng quố
ác
và video đến đây là kết thúc và xin chào
các bạn